so I've been getting a ton of emails
from the supporters of different
presidential candidates who are getting
in touch and saying David you have to
cover something about this one candidate
who made the next debate or didn't make
the next debate or whatever and then I
got a lot of emails from people who
aren't supporting those candidates
saying David please don't do an entire
story about how X is going to the debate
or Y is going to the debate is not going
to the debate this is not worthy of a
full segment so here's how I'll make
everybody happy
or no one happy which is let's just do a
roundup of what's going on with the
debate next week which is the sixth
democratic debate Andrew yang has
qualified for the next debate on
December 19th Tulsi Gabbard has
announced she's not going to the next
debate even though she hasn't qualified
so it's not really much of a choice
Kamala Harris has qualified but has
dropped out of the campaign and won't be
going and then there is discussion about
whether the DNC is going to change the
rules to allow Michael Bloomberg to may
be qualify for future debates so let's
go through these one by one as of right
now the qualified candidates for debate
number six are Biden Sanders Warren
Budaj Klobuchar Tom Steyer Andrew yang
and Kamala Harris that's eight but as I
mentioned Kamala Harris has ended her
presidential campaign and won't be
attending as I said last week I respect
this it's very tempting even if you know
you can't win the nomination to just
stick it out and get another night in
front of the cameras on public on
national television
Kamala chose not to do it and I respect
her for doing that then we had this big
announcement from Tulsi Gabbard where
she said on Twitter quote for a number
of reasons I've decided not to attend
the December 19th quote debate
regardless of whether or not there are
qualifying polls I think she means
regardless of whether there are
qualifying called polls I instead choose
to spend that precious time
directly meeting with and hearing from
the people of New Hampshire and South
Carolina now Tulsi happens to be polling
literally zero in two of the most recent
six national polls she's not qualified
for the debate and she is unlikely to
qualify for that debate so she's using
this as a PR stunt saying she won't be a
ten
yeah we know you didn't make it you're
not invited and that's fine she won't be
clogging up the stage I'm glad for her
to tweet whatever she wants the concern
that's growing is that she's setting up
this adversarial public thing with the
DNC to eventually announce that she's
running third party which would have a
very unpredictable effect we will dig in
more to that if it actually happens then
we have Andrew yang qualifying a polling
four in the last Quinnipiac poll four in
the latest morning consult poll so he's
in and maybe this time he will be
actually allowed to say more than just a
couple of things he got very little talk
time in debate number five on MSNBC so
that's great news for Andrew yang now
lastly let's talk about Michael
Bloomberg Bloomberg is actually polling
okay so far he very quickly has gotten a
five in a couple of polls six in a
recent poll his issue is he's not taking
donations which is an issue in the sense
that there's a donor requirement to make
the debates so there's a few articles
floating around about how the DNC is
going to have a choice to make do they
want to get rid of the donor requirement
in order to give Bloomberg the
possibility of making the debates now I
don't know that the DNC wants Bloomberg
on the stage it seems sort of lose-lose
for them if they change the rules and
let Bloomberg into the debate assuming
he gets the required polling support
every other candidate would rightly flip
out and say that's not fair
we've all had five debates six debates
already with the rules now the rules are
changed for Bloomberg halfway through or
it's getting towards the end of the
debate season they would be right to
flip out at the same time imagine that
all of Bloomberg's campaign ad spending
works and he keeps polling five six even
7% not having him on the stage is sort
of weird because he would be polling
much better than a number of the
candidates that do make the stage but
these are the rules the DNC said and as
we know that you know live by the rules
die by the rules I have no idea what
they will do so my question to you is
aside from the reality that number one
we don't need another billionaire on
stage and number two buying your way
onto the stage is just the sickening
reality of status quo political campaign
financing and we're disgusted by it
if Bloomberg is
Halling five or six should he be on the
debate stage from the purposes of
participating in the conversation I
don't have an answer I want to hear from
you about it
today's program is sponsored in part by
Blink asam / Pakman if you've not
already heard about bling 'kiss
it's amazing it's an app for your phone
tablet or web browser and what they do
is they take nonfiction books popular
nonfiction critically acclaimed
nonfiction they condense the book into a
fifteen minute audio book you get all
the most important information and
insights from each book but you can soak
up the entire essence of the book in one
sitting I've listened to a ton of books
on blinkin
recent one is a Robert Rice's new book
the common good
also bunk by Kevin Young useful in
preparing me for the pseudo-science
miniseries that we're producing and if
you are a David Pakman show viewer or
listener you can get a seven day free
trial by going to blink accom slash
Pakman if you're watching on youtube use
the link in the video description
after the free trial if you like it you
can get the full access to thousands of
condensed audiobooks for about five
bucks a month that's be li NK is t.com
/pa ke ma n